hi friends welcome back to the modern
wisdom podcast my guest today is David
Pierce we're going to be talking all
things transhumanism that is not talking
about people changing their genders but
it is exploring some very exciting topic
areas which I've wanted to sink my teeth
into for a while
so today expect to learn why suffering
of any kind is an artifact that might
have been useful to our ancestors but is
something that we need to transcend as
soon as possible how David thinks that
humanity not only should but also must
progress towards a more hedonic
imperative the hard problem of
consciousness and why we might not be
uploading our brains into computers
anytime soon and a lot of interesting
discussions about the implications of
CRISPR and gene editing on the whole we
cover a lot of topics that I definitely
should have been much more well-educated
on seeing as they have massive
implications and are also pretty current
to society right now but yet I loved the
conversation David is a massively
prominent figure in the transhumanism
movement and I feel very privileged to
have had him on teaching us the 101 of
transhumanism so without further ado
please welcome David Pearce
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by David Pierce today David
welcome to the show
hi Chris it's good to be with you
fantastic to have you on today also nice
to hear a familiar accent so we're
talking about transhumanism today this
will be a new venture for a lot of the
listeners so let's start off with a
definition can you can you tell us what
transhumanism is well there are no
sacred texts but very simplistically I
sometimes talk about the three Super's
three super source of transhumanism
super intelligence this is the idea that
it's going to be possible to radically
amplify our intelligence and machine
intelligence and there are different
ways one can go about this there are
different conceptions of post-humans
super intelligence but that's one of the
three supers then there is super
longevity this is the idea that there is
no immutable law of nature that says
that biological robots must grow old and
die whereas silicon robots can be
repaired indefinitely and transhumanists
believe in radical life extension
indefinite youth with the backup of
cryonics or maybe even crazier bikal for
any of your listeners who perhaps of a
certain age think that realistically
they're not going to make it and the
third super which is the super I focus
on most of all super happiness or self
or super well-being this is the idea
that it's going to be possible to
replace the biology of pain and misery
and suffering with life based entirely
on gradients of intelligent well-being
this is replacing the biology of
suffering not just in humans but in the
long run the rest of the animal kingdom
throughout the living world now as well
as those three supers there are plenty
of transhumanists who would want to add
a fourth
super they don't agree what that might
be after example what about super
empathy but I would argue that this is
embraced by any sufficiently rich
conception of super intelligence that a
full spectrum super intelligence
wouldn't just have an off the scale IQ
it would also have a super human
capacity for perspective taking
empathetic understanding so there in a
nutshell fantastic it's no small task I
think is one way to kind of summarize
the the transhumanist movement then
interestingly I had professor David
Sinclair on recently who you may know
right yes indeed yes yes I had him on
not long ago talking about the cutting
edge longevity research that he's doing
and during that I asked him do you think
that human could live for a thousand
years and his short answer was yes so
it's it's interesting to hear that
people from multiple fields very
different fields from coming out from
genetics and gene editing coming at it
from this longevity research and then
your side as well are all pointing in a
similar direction yes I think a lot of
people psychologically would switch off
if one we're to say well look at
grandchildren won't go old and die but
you will I mean there's something always
rule about telling people that science
is going to find a cure for aging
shortly after you're dead and I know
don't know this unlike most
transhumanists I'm not shall we say one
of life's temperamental optimists but
nonetheless as I said as well as
supporting research into anti aging
technologies there is one strand of the
super longevity aspect of transhumanism
that is focused on cryonics and even
crazier so what are those two terms for
us but essentially sorry I should say
this is the I this is the idea that if
you are suspended in
tamal conditions that as so long as
irreversible information loss doesn't
occur it would be possible to reanimate
you at some future date when what when
there is a cure for whatever killed you
now it is extremely difficult in a
technical sense to destroy information
some physicists would say impossible but
nonetheless I would say a bit a big
imponderable is whether that people who
are frozen a long time by but a long
time I mean hours after their nominal
death whether it will be possible to
reanimate them that in practice
deterioration may be too far advanced
but in principle at any rate one could
have something like cryo and ACO rather
than waiting until you're 95 and Gaga
have yourself suspended where you are
still carry say in there in the prime of
life it hasn't been done yet but this is
this this would be one possible option
that sounds an awful lot like a book
that I've just about finished have you
read children of time by Adrienne
Tchaikovsky I blush to say it is now
many many years since I've read a novel
that is so it was the it was the winner
of the 2016 arthur c clarke award and it
was the 30th anniversary one as well so
they gave it out to a fantastic book and
in that they have people who dip in and
out of suspended animation these long
sleeps for going across big vast
galactic distances between different
different star systems and stuff like
that and they jump in and out of it like
you'd like you'd get a shower but it
sounds it sounds like the the technology
for that's a little bit further away so
moving on to your particular domain of
competence you were talking about super
happiness yes once again that's that's
just a slogan but yes if you think of
perhaps today's hedonic Rangers
- ten - zero to +10 with -10 being the
absolute pit of despair on barrel right
parable agony hedonic zero being
emotionally neutral experience and plus
ten being the most wonderful peak
experience of your life imagine if it
were possible to engineer a civilization
that let's say stretched from + 72 +
hundred now if that sounds too much like
a science fiction well that may well be
the the case and much more morally
urgent I think is focusing on the
sub-zero states that plague so many
lives today that sadly natural selection
didn't optimize us for being happy it
optimized us for leaving more copies of
our genes or evolutionary biologists
like to say to maximize inclusive
genetic fitness and yeah there's no real
convincing scientific evidence that on
average we are happier or sadder or more
or less contented or discontented today
than we were on the African savannah
which is very counterintuitive but yeah
the hedonic treadmill is designed he was
discontented a lot of the time
essentially because it's it's good it's
good for our genes and if we are serious
about getting rid of pain and suffering
we're going to have to tackle its
genetic biological roots I mean that may
sound like crude genetic determinism in
practice one is going to need a
twin-track approach you know everything
from basic income to decent
accommodation health care and so forth
all all the kind of environmental
stopgaps yes but if we're ever to get
rid of the horrors of depression anxiety
disorders is actually all the nasty
aspects of Darwinian life we're gonna
have to edit
genetic source code and perhaps the
first thing I think we should do is you
know prospect prospective parents at the
moment does one have a genetic crapshoot
and recall every child born today is a
unique understood genetic experiment or
it does one try to load the genetic dice
in favor of ons offspring by giving them
a high hedonic set point high pain
threshold and trays like that now I
think there are real ethical questions
about whether one really wants to bring
more pain and suffering into the world
but given most people do want to have
kids I think the best one can do is is
is urge them to yeah first of all
consider pre-implantation genetic
screening and soon CRISPR genome editing
yeah I was listening to Jamie Metzl on
Joe Rogan just earlier on today do you
know Jamie have you heard of his work
yes
yes so I was listening to those two go
at it and a lot of these topics came up
I think CRISPR at the moment is kind of
a hot topic for the ethical questions
that it's offering but Jamie offered a
really interesting point which was he
said in the future he thinks that
parents who potentially have biological
typically biological births are maybe
going to be seen in as irresponsible in
the same way as parents who don't
vaccinate their children now that if you
had the choice of choosing through IVF
or whatever advanced version of that is
this what was embryonic selection
perhaps pre-implantation genetic
screening this isn't the same as as
actual genome editing which a lot of
people regardless more more radical it's
simply choosing what mother nature has
has has thrown up but ultimately it's
it's a false distinction and yes it I
think it's a good parallel that yes the
most of history yes one just has to add
trust mother nature God fate Providence
or whatnot but increasingly it's
to be a matter responsible parents are
going to be choosing the genetic makeup
trays of their future offspring and the
very nature of selection pressure is
going to change to a natural selection
sexual selection it's it's it's blind
and based on random genetic variations
whereas increasingly as the reproductive
revolution unfolds I think there's going
to be selection pressure in favor of
life based on gradients of well-being
but that's obviously speculative yeah
it's it's interesting I'm sure a lot of
people who are listening will be
thinking the same as me which is there's
a very odd visceral reaction that I have
about this selective birth it may create
these feelings of unease and I can't
work out why and I'm fairly
forward-thinking with regards to this I
find technological progress exciting
probably above everything else exciting
ahead of scary probably so and even for
me there's something about that and yet
you can draw parallels that had you have
told people a thousand years ago that
you'd be able to fly across oceans or
had you have told people five thousand
years ago that you'd be able to get an
injection that would stop them from
dying from all of the things that are
constantly killing them and their family
or you could take a pill and it would
stop you from feeling sick all of these
things at that point would have been
felt or would have been considered
unnatural is this just another frontier
or is is there actually something
different about what the the movement
that we're going towards here well this
time it's different but then it always
is any of your listeners who are
thinking of all of the kind of the
possible things that can go wrong I
think it's it's it's it's a healthy
suspicion that yeah there needs to be
exhaustive risk/reward analysis you know
the thinking of all the conceivable
things that can that can go can go wrong
I mean eligibly there are a lot of
people this kind of reflex eugenics the
Third Reich
race hygiene other people will say brave
new world another reason is that when we
try to imagine the future there was a
lot of neurological evidence that what
we're doing is drawing upon memory and
the memory which we're drawing on is
essentially sci-fi often sci-fi read
when we were kids and sure half-digested
memories of everything from you know
kind of Gattaca or in the case of super
intelligence Skynet
so yeah I'm you know as I said I very
much sympathize with anyone who is
suspicious and who is pessimistic
nonetheless if we are to get rid of the
horrific burden of suffering in the
world we're gonna have to tackle it in
its genetic source essentially ad jeans
designed us to be unhappy and
discontented a lot of the time and then
this we actually do edit and genetic
source code there is going to be obscene
misery and suffering in the world
indefinitely I use sometimes surprised
that we manage to have lives of the
degree of happiness that we do given a
genetic predisposition yes at times this
is it nature seems to just sort of play
around with the dials and that though
sadly there are a very significant
minority of people who enjoy kind of
chronic misery pain depression equally
there are life's temperamental optimists
and even extreme genetic outliers who
spend most of their lives yes extremely
happy which is kind of existence proof
essentially being temperamental II very
happy it's a kind of high-risk
high-reward one is more likely to go out
do things explore the world take risks
and so on if one is a happy
extroverted go-getter whereas if you
have Loman low mood you're more likely
to keep your head down it's kind of low
risk low reward and that's very crude
dichotomy yeah but yeah most people on
balance love life I mean I might given
my rather gloomy and depressive
temperament think of Iranian life as
sentient malware but this is very much
the minority position and yeah one
needn't be a Buddhist or a negative
utilitarian to believe that we should
aim to prevent and minimize unnecessary
suffering and what seems quite
counterintuitive is the idea that all
suffering all experience below hedonic
zero is going to become technically
optional that it sure suffering in one's
life sometimes but only sometimes
sometimes it can be instructive and
valuable but the critical question to
ask is is it functionally indispensable
and as Silicon robots machine
intelligence AI progressively eclipses
humans in their ever more cognitive
domains without the nasty roar feels of
pain and suffering I think we just have
to face up to the fact that you know
that suffering is just a ghastly
implementation detail of Darwinian life
and we ought to be switching to a more
civilized signalling system instead yeah
it's this odd artifact that's come along
for the ride hasn't it so the I want to
talk about the hedonistic imperative and
the abolitionist project both of which
you're you're big proponents of would
you be able to explain to the listeners
what those are please
yesiree the hedonistic imperative was
the name of an online manifesto I wrote
back in 1995 why the hedonistic
imperative well I would really have
liked call it you know the moral
imperative to use biotechnology to sound
suffering throughout the living world
but of course no one needs something
snappy and catchy so I think your
marketing is better on this one David I
think I think works I mean it's not
ideal because hedonism can make
something vaguely shallow and a and a
moral stock don't you yeah whereas I do
see there is a desperate moral urgency
to get getting rid of suffering but in a
nutshell yeah it gives the it gives the
gist the abolitionist project really
just alludes to yeah getting rid of
suffering in both human and non-human
animals for Biotechnology how far one
goes beyond this yeah though personally
I'm a negative utilitarian I think that
over riding obligation is to get rid of
suffering and then everything else it's
a bonus
icing on the cake nonetheless yes I do
foresee a civilization where they're
their darkest those are richer than
today's peak experiences but that
probably strikes most people as science
fiction and that anyone from all
down-to-earth temperament I would yes a
stress more the the issue of suffering
you I understand
so getting towards the the rubber
meeting the road so to speak how how are
we beginning to go about that what's the
beginning of the proposed strategy the
next steps from now and then where does
that lead us to in the the longer term
like the real far future well a lot of
futurology consists
of extrapolation which is dangerous and
sadly though we are just beginning you
know the first CRISPR babies if you
think of a scandal earth is this Chinese
research who did it allegedly without
authorization of her well well I was
thinking more of the the state we now
know that not merely did yes don't
really did the researcher a able to make
the kids protected against HIV that
purely inadvertently it seems memory and
intelligence may have been enhanced no
fiends involved in in cognitive
augmentation I'm personally rather
skeptical that this was a mere oversight
in yes so I mean that said yes we are
starting to pinpoint specific genes and
allelic combinations involved in low
mood pain sensitivity and even today if
we are ethically serious it is possible
to choose by pre-implantation genetic
screening or CRISPR genome editing
ensuring that your kid has let's say
okay start an extremely high pain
threshold why not to polish pain
altogether well maybe one day it's going
to be possible to do so with smart
prosthesis or literally gradients of
bliss but just for now leaving the
sci-fi aside if you give your kid let's
say a benign version of the SCN nine AG
SC n9a is a pain modulating gene there's
as dozens of different alleles different
variations nonsense mutations no pasty
to experience pain at all but other
mutations high although pain sensitivity
and by doing this essentially you can
ensure that you know if you've ever met
the kind of person today's
outliers who do the comparison who says
that pain it's just a useful signaling
mechanism before we get rid of pain
altogether be possible to kind of
ratchet up pain thresholds we need to be
done with care for example you know the
woods do people with extremely high pain
thresholds not show perhaps sufficient
empathy for the plight of plight of
others it's the kind of thing to
consider but none of those other things
being equal one wants to give kids high
pain threshold the other tre I think one
would wish to focus on is hedonic
setpoint
I don't accept point this is this
approximate level of well-being or
ill-being that most people tend to
fluctuate around in the course for
lifetime and some people have very high
he don't accept point other people low
hit on it set point and though one can't
point to a single gene that is decisive
here nonetheless there are a handful of
genes associated with her with rather
particular alleles associated with
having a high hedonic set point and do
we want to ensure that future our
children do have this hedonic high he'd
um except for today is genetic crapshoot
and I think the genetic crapshoot is is
unethical
of course as well as as well as our kids
understandably most of us want to feel
better ourselves and I yes of course
these designer drugs mood brighteners
new nootropics
there are a number of possible
interventions there but at the risk of
sounding very boring and conservative
given that given the degree of our
ignorance still I believe in a lot of
anyone emails meter watts or pills do
you recommend
yeah briefer far better to initially at
least focus on this Trinity of good
sleep discipline optimal aerobic
exercise
and and and diet good nutrition that
sounds rather boring but so few people
really get these optimal but obviously
there are pharmacological interventions
- yeah a couple of points there firstly
the the last thing that you touched on
about people seeming to think that there
needs to be a very fancy solution to a
very complicated problem we often talk
about the use of people to do to jump on
the back of nootropics or caffeine abuse
in an effort to become more productive
when they're unable to do deep work or
stay focused on one task for 10 minutes
or they don't understand how to task
manage they don't understand how to
capture or process or review their their
to-do list for instance and it's the
equivalent of taking steroids having
never been to the gym for us that you
you're going a lot faster in the wrong
direction yes and all too many of
today's drugs rather than cheating the
hedonic treadmill actually kicked into
gear with it with a vengeance
so yes I'm actually though I write about
and discuss discuss different mood
brighteners drugs have well known
pitfalls I mean one of the biggest
pitfalls unfortunately is that the
neurotransmitter system most involve
directly involved in hedonic tone
whether one feels good or bad is the
opioid system the mute receptor and
opioids obviously have very well-known
pitfalls so be much better if we were
designed genetically to have high
hedonic set points rather than needing
to repair nature's deficiencies yes I
understand
moving to the point that you made about
pain one of the first things that comes
to mind is surely do we not need pain I
need to know if I put my hand in some
hot water I need to know if a car's run
over my foot etc etc if people are just
walking around in this numb state of not
knowing what's going on is that not
they're not some downstream negatives Oh
indeed this is yeah people born with
congenital insensitivity to pain lead
need to leader a cotton-wool existence I
mean the wire they would just have died
and they're more likely to take risks
however there are other people who just
simply have an extremely high pain
threshold there was the case of Joe
Cameron this this Scottish lady
responsible retired schoolteacher vegan
and I came to interested medical
professionals because she waved away
painkillers and the like because she
just didn't feel she needed them after
what Autry had extremely painful
medical procedures he describes
childbirth as a mere tickle someone with
complete insensitivity it seems as
though she just naturally has an
extremely high pain threshold and
genetic and and research suggested that
she had mutations in two genes in
particular they far and what's being
christened the far out a gene which are
responsible for an and alive the
breakdown of an and amide and and amide
is literally etymologically blissed
molecule and she naturally high levels
of an and amide and she peers to have
gone through life in a state of of mild
YouView euphoria but not
but I but as I said I said that
responsible pillar of the local
community
vegan respire a school teacher and one
obviously needs to be extremely wary of
placing too much faith in individual
case case studies but only another
example I gave is yeah my transhumanist
colleague and the Sandberg who just
acknowledge I do have a ridiculously
high hedonic set point what is this it's
back to your your original question what
is critical to intelligent behavior to
responding adaptively to to noxious
stimuli isn't one's absolute place on
the plane or pay pleasure scale it's
some kind of hedonic gradient and yeah
one might imagine that people who are
just exceptionally happy would be less
motivated to be a adaptively but counter
intuitively this doesn't seem to be the
case that other things being equal the
more the more you love life the more
you're motivated to protect and and
present preserve it whereas it's
depressives who get stuck in iraq the
experience learned helplessness
behavioral despair sometimes so
self-destructive behavior but preserving
in yeah information sensitivity there
just distinction between being blissful
and and blissed-out yeah I think that's
that's something that was in the back of
my mind that if it's a world where
essentially everyone's walking around on
MDMA like 100x MDMA sensations but a
little bit more sober and able to
remember what's going on I I wonder how
useful that society would be I think
there's some parallels that can probably
be drawn between that as a genetic or
pharmacological solution and some of the
concerns people have with the universal
basic income that when you take away
people what
is considered to be people's current
reason for living that they'll be left
in this kind of wallowy state where
everyone's just lying around eating
skittles on bean bags and stuff yes yes
sorry I mean in the case of universal
basic income I think it's just a matter
of any decent society will have
something like universal basic income
and get rid of this
it's a balling sprawling welfare
bureaucracy but nonetheless I mean that
the basic yeah can be relatively basic
that I I don't well I won't go off on a
long spiel there it's very easy it's
very easy to you know to sound off
setting the world to rights but yeah I'm
the whole I don't tackle the social
issues to the same degree I mean I do
have views on everything from Donald
Trump to climate change to you name it
but the point is other people have said
it better so yeah you've got you've got
some some fairly niche down stuff that
you need to be working on as well I
think you can you can leave the politics
to to some other people um so one of the
things that I'm thinking about straight
off the bat having read super
intelligence by Nick Bostrom listeners
of the show will know that I found the
book both testing and very very
fascinating rather than being selective
with our genes or using particular drugs
or whatever it might be to edit the way
that we exist in the real world why not
just do whole brain emulation or upload
ourselves to the Internet
ooh difficult question because this
brings us to the nature of consciousness
and the binding problem let's jump into
it David come on let's your feet first
into the binding problem my friend we're
in at the deep end now okay the hard
problem and the binding problem are
worth distinguishing though they're
interrelated the hard problem is why
does consciousness exist at all why
aren't we P zombies nothing in the laws
of physics is understood today if one
assumes that basic understanding of the
world quantum field theory describes
fields of in sentience rather than
sentient if what makes that very modest
assumption nothing in today's physics
and chemistry forbids you and I be
talking to each other now and we are
both being piece on B's so as the
question appears on oh sorry
philosophical zombies this is acts in
exactly the same way as you or me but
isn't conscious isn't sentient and I
think the interesting question isn't the
the sceptical question how do I know
that you're not appease I'll be the
interesting question is why aren't we be
zombies how is it possible for
consciousness to have the causal
capacity to allow us to pose questions
about its existence for instance so yeah
that's in a nutshell the hard problem
the binding problem which probably few
people are familiar with is that even if
you think that consciousness is
absolutely fundamental to the world why
aren't we so called micro experiential
zombies and the population amusing
example I mean here is you know the
population of United States let's say
three head so yeah what's the population
of the United States not too sure give
me one second and I will tell you it's
it is three hundred and twenty seven
point two million three hundred and TRAI
now simply the fact that one has 327
million skull bound mines however they
intercommunicate nonetheless with no
reason to think that the population of
the united states is a mind a unitary
bound mind or one can't be sure that the
population of the USA isn't a unitary
subjective experience but that kind of
strong emergence would be some kind of
spooky it's difficult to reconcile with
monistic physicalism well the question
is why are our brains any different
after all you and me we are yeah 86
billion membrane bound nerve cells even
if you think that individual nerve cells
maybe kind of support rudimentary
consciousness rudimentary experience why
aren't we just micro experiential
zombies just patterns of mine dust and
so yeah that is the the binding problem
and yeah Here I am very much out on a
limb I don't think phenomenal binding is
it's a classical phenomenon quantum mind
there are powerful arguments against
this but less controversial II today's
classical digital computers are not
subjects of experience and simply
increasing speed of execution their
complexity or even making the massively
parallel there's no reason to think that
sentience is somehow going to switch on
so it's less it's it's not a case of I
think some Harris talks about it being
that with processing power consciousness
comes along for the ride
and well I mean yeah I suppose a lot of
researchers sort of a variety
researchers do assume that at some time
in future our machines will become
conscious but personally I think the
idea that consciousness arises that some
some kind of computational level of
abstraction is is is is is a mistake and
that I don't think classical digital
computers are ever going to be more than
zombies so therefore I don't think you
are I ever going to be uploading
ourselves yes into digital computers
blow stress this is obviously a
controversial topic you you mentioned
yeah Nick's book on super intelligence
very very crudely there are a bunch
transhumanists there there are three
quite different conceptions of of super
intelligence the fascinating tell us
about them okay there is one conception
of super intelligence and this is when I
personally subscribe to that essentially
post humans super intelligence will be
us that recursively self-improving
biological robots are going to edit
their own source code and bootstrap our
way to full spectrum super intelligence
critic and critically with the aid of
narrow AI that essentially all the all
the kind of clever machine you know or
all all the stuff one reads about
essentially we're going to be
incorporating it within ourselves neuro
chip smart prosthesis and just as you
know I could be Kasper off today with a
neuro chip and cheating but number
that's still one I still likewise there
is so that this kind of intimate neuro
face but I mean yeah yeah I I don't
think
[Laughter]
digital creatures ever going to become
conscious per se okay that's one there's
one conception of super intelligent
super intelligence as our ultimately our
biological descendants transhumans and
post humans then there is another
conception of super intelligence
associated with Ray Kurzweil that
essentially yeah sees us as completely
merging with our machines possibly
involving yes to mind uploading that any
distinction between humans now machines
will become completely meaningless
that's the second conception but there
is a third conception of posthuman super
intelligence originally I came up with
by I J good mathematician in the 1960s
developed by Eliezer you can't ski and
his colleagues at Miri and and put in
its most Magisterial form by Nick in his
book super intelligence which is
essentially sees a combination and it's
just the combination of Moore's law ie
exponential increase in computer
processing power together with
recursively self-improving software
based AI that is software that improves
itself in this escalating cycle and on
this conception of posthuman super
intelligence there's no particular
reason to expect that AI artificial
general intelligence will be will be
sentient friendly human friendly may
it's it's values may be perhaps
completely orthogonal so I'm glossing
over all manner of complications here
but if someone does start talking about
super intelligence it's it's worth
probing what they mean I mean I I for
instance think that a full spectrum
super intelligence will follow such
things as it
exploring radically altered state spaces
of consciousness and it's it's it's it's
unclear what it would mean for a digital
zombie to start exploring altered state
spaces yeah yeah I I understand that's a
it's interesting to hear different
stances or different viewpoints on the
future super intelligence movement so to
speak
certainly navarre who is a big big hero
of mine when it comes to the podcasting
space he talks about the fact that
recently there hasn't really been an
awful lot of movement towards artificial
general intelligence I think people look
at stuff like alphago zero and these
sort of programs which are simulacrum
zuv human intelligence but in an
incredibly narrow domain and the domain
is getting increasingly complex but not
actually wider and he talks about the
fact that any progress in general
artificial intelligence kind of hasn't
that hasn't really been very many
developments and that kind of lends
credence towards what you were saying
which is that you will have the head of
the mothership still being reliant on
the biological system that we are and
then you're augmenting with the narrow
AI within its capabilities to to add on
the functions that we need yes also risk
well essentially when one is talking
about super intelligence in practice one
ends up justic obliquely expressing
one's own limitations I can't step
outside myself and really obviously tell
you what will be the nature of full
spectrum super intelligence I would just
urge sherice a degree of caution before
assuming that AI is somehow going to to
wake up I understand so one of the
questions that Joe Rogan asked Jamie
Matz all the other day was why we have
this insatiable
to try and improve ourselves do you
think that that's the way that were
wired and and if that's the case isn't
that quite a poetically beautiful way
for us to transcend our own genetics hi
yes so this is back to natural selection
designed us to be discontented a lot of
the time I wouldn't say all of us at
least even most of us necessarily spend
our try and trying to improve ourselves
but certainly not many people think well
I've had enough I've got enough money or
I've had enough reproductive
opportunities and so on the others other
things being equal wanting more is
Fitness enhancing so so yes yes I
understand completely
so moving on one question that I really
wanted to ask was if you had the
opportunity to create a wish list of
advisers to help the government
understand the future and where they
should be directing research and funds
would you be able to put together a
little dream team of advisers for them
and would you be able to tell us why you
choose those people um I probably could
but just not off my head like that it
would also be invidious to I would love
to be able to do so I mean as yet no
shall we say billionaire or corporate
Colossus as as approached me with a
funding but yes it's it's in the post
David I promise both mate I think it
will be so in terms of risks other
things that are at the forefront of your
of your thinking that you're concerned
about as we move forward with this are
the risks to the way that the project
can go the way that the public perceives
it or more
kind of nitty-gritty concerns to do with
the actual way in which we proceed
towards the the hedonistic imperative
yeah by risks and there are some people
including some transhumanists who think
of life is fundamentally good and we
don't want to put it all at risk where
is my conception of life today frankly
is much bleaker
that's the non-human animals in our
factory farms some slaughterhouses are
as sentient as pre-linguistic toddlers
um what one if one is being more careful
one has to say that a pig for example is
demonstrably more sapience than
pre-linguistic toddler one can't be
certain that the pig is as sentient
nonetheless the actual particular
structures neurological structures genes
neurotransmitters that mediate our most
powerful experiences of panic of pain
distress are nearly identical so short
of radical skepticism or solipsism yes I
I am as confident that a big is
associate as I am that your your
sentient and so yes given what I think
posterity will recognize as you know
crime against sentience of almost
unimaginable proportions I think perhaps
our most urgent priority right now is
just to get factory farms and
slaughterhouses shutting out Lourdes now
moral argument clearly plays a role but
I'm quite cynical about human nature I
think we're going to need to develop
hasten the development and
commercialization of in-vitro meat meat
meat substitutes it's not a
distinctively transhumanist technology
in vitro meat in vitro meat could be
genetically engineered it's much more
likely to be widely accepted if it's not
but yeah essentially I I would see yeah
we have this this absolute moral
obligation to get factory farms
slaughterhouses shut that I think heaven
knows how will explain what we did to
our to it to our grandchildren so yeah I
mean though I can happily talk to you
about all the wonderful transhumanist
technologies and ideas for the future I
think part of creating a world based on
gradients of intelligent bliss involves
stopping systematically harming sentient
beings we can't we can't be serious
about trying to build a happy biosphere
if we're systematically harming others
to gratify our own appetites yeah it's
an interesting perspective to be able to
try and take yourself away from your
current experience and almost imagine
the remembered self looking from the
future that degree of perspective I
think is something that not a lot of
people are are used to doing it's
obvious that when you do look at it with
in black and white you are correct that
you're breeding animals to suffer purely
for your own enjoyment to eat it's it's
a difficult to difficult justification
to make yeah I mean personally I yeah
it's completely ethically indefensible I
mean actually I should add that you know
by an accident of birth I've never even
tasted tasty meat so it's not I mean as
I said it's not that I'm trying to
parade my moral superiority belief one
hasn't got this there's this source of
buyers yeah seeing what we are do you
know on leads
some let's say some horrific case of
child abuse in the papers and some
viscerally is feeling God's this
terrible abuse ought to be locked up for
to life but then you yet you see you
know across the table someone tucking
into a bacon sandwich it's yeah yeah if
I passed the you know the meat counter
and a supermarket I I think of a schvitz
and I think of child abuse and people
are actually own one of these videos
about what goes on in factory farms and
slaughterhouses some people seem
genuinely genuinely shocked but yeah you
know far worse things go on off-camera
yeah it's it's yeah it really is
unspeakable yeah fantastic
so David before we wrap up I wanted to
ask for a suggestion of a book or a
resource or a blog which you would
recommend if people think this was a an
interesting discussion I'd quite like to
find out some more about transhumanism
and the transhumanist movement oh
heavens
well I on the spot again Davis I'm not
letting you slide sidle out of this one
like the government advises things in
spite of my low testosterone I ain't
going to say back in 1995 when the web
was young I've had she was nineteen
ninety six I set up a mother lode
website head web calm h GD w e be calm
and though a lot of the material there
is dated certainly the style nonetheless
everything from quarrels about
transhumanism to yeah the core of the
manifesto together with links to other
transhumanist resources and yeah if if
what if what I've been talking to you
about does strike a chord yeah there
plenty of hot links there but Chris yeah
very much appreciated it
it's been great chatting if this
fantastic head web.com will be linked in
the show notes below as long as well as
some of the resources which we've been
going through today David I really found
today fascinating hopefully within the
next the next few years we might be
coming back on to discuss some exciting
new developments in the in the world of
transhumanism but for now we'll catch
you later on thank you so much for your
time
fantastic Chris
[Music]
you